my dad did upholstery on cars my mom um  so did whatever odd jobs  um  but my dad was always like if you want  something you have to earn it and to his  credit he never said no you can't do  that so whether it was selling garbage  bags baseball cards stamps whatever it  was he never held me back and so i think  that was as important as anything and  you know sometimes being young and  trying things you're so naive and you  don't know any better all you do is  learn and if you fail it doesn't matter  and so whether i was 9 10 12 16 21  the failures were irrelevant and you  know whether you're you know 9 12 16 21  22 24 you know i'm sleeping on the couch  you know i have a car with a hole in the  floorboard you know i'm i'm living like  a bum and like a student and so what did  i have to lose and so i think that  influenced me as much as anything so  you know my dad was like go for it you  know don't why not what have you got to  lose you know you have to sleep on a  different couch